Attends ma chérie, c’est toi qui a fait ça ?
Ouais, ça te plaît ?
T’es trop douée, c’est fou.
Merci, tu sais moi, tout ce qui
est atelier créatif
DIY et tout, j’adore, donc.
Je vais la poster sur Insta.
Zoé, ma chérie ?
- Regarde.
- La vache.
C’est mon premier bonhomme de neige.
Je l’ai faite toute seule,
je viens de le poster sur Instagram.
- Déjà ?
- Je l’ai fait un peu plus fit que le tien.
Et surtout j’ai mis un peu de couleur.
De la couleur Alice ?
Ouais, j’ai trouvé de la neige jaune, à côté.
Ça réhausse un peu le teint.
Tu te doutes bien que la neige jaune
c’est soit de la pisse de clodo,
soit de la pisse de chien.
Bah oui.
Oh, non.
Ah oui y’a l’odeur qui vient avec.
- Zoé, s’il te plaît fais quelque chose.
- Ah non ça dégoûte.
J’espère que c’est végan.
Parce que moi je mange rien
qui provient des animaux.
Mais je sais Zoé, t’inquiète pas
Ils font du faux fromage, de la fausse charcuterie
T’inquiète pas, laisse-moi faire, tu vas adorer.
Ok.
Mais c’est incroyable, on dirait du vrai.
Ils sont forts.
Ah ouais, ils sont hyper forts.
Tu m’as menti Alice ?
Bon bah ça va, ça fait pas trois jours
que je me pèle les miches
pour passer à côté de la raclette de ma vie
parce que Madame a regardé
trop de vidéos d’abattoir sur Facebook
Maintenant qu’on a commencé on termine
ça sera notre petit secret entre nous
En rentrant, tu feras une petite photo de müesli sur Instagram
et tout le monde sera content, OK ?
Bon d’accord, mais tu le dis à personne alors.
Mais oui.
Alice !
Un petit souvenir.
Donc je vais prendre ça,
plus des chaussures de ski en quarante
et je vais prendre des skis en blanc.
Moi je vais faire tout pareil.
Sauf qu’en fait, je vais les prendre en noir et en 38
Vous les montez directement dans notre chambre ?
Merci !
Attendez.
Faut payer.
On vous tag sur une photo Insta.
Il est fou lui, il voulait qu’on le paye comment ?
Je sais pas, je crois qu’il voulait qu’on couche avec lui
le malade.
Trop cool.
Qu’est-ce que tu fais ?
C’est bon, on a fait la photo,
on peut rentrer à l’hôtel.
Les gens vont croire qu’on a fait du ski.
Mais tu plaisante ou quoi ?
Je me suis pas tapé 7h
de train-couchette avec des pauvres
pour en plus pas faire de ski du tout.
Viens on va au spa.
Alice on fait au moins une montée.
Si t’es mon amie, on fait au moins une montée.
OK, une.
Pourquoi tu m’obliges à crier sur toi ?
Bah Alice, qu’est-ce que tu fais ?
C’est bon, je suis montée.
Non mais t’es sérieuse là,
tu vas me laisser toute seule ?
Je te retrouve à l’hôtel
Oh la la, mais la vue est trop belle
je vais faire des photos incroyables.
Quoi ? fais voir !
Y’a une bébé marmotte !
Elle est trop belle.
Oh la la, génial.
J’adore.
Oh regarde, là-bas, c’est trop beau.
Là ici, c’est parfait.
Ouais vas-y prends une photo.
C’est ton baton.
Avec quoi je ski depuis tout à l’heure moi ?
Merde
Il est où ton téléphone ?
Mais appelle !
Je te fais sonner, ne panique pas.
Tu me fais paniquer, d’accord ?
Tu entends vibrer la montagne ?
Moi si je le retrouve pas je rentre.
Attends, ne panique pas.
Mais donne pas des coups de bâtons tu vas le défoncer.
Ça à été le ski ma chérie ?
Alice, il faut que tu m’aides.
Bah oui.
J’ai acheté toute la Biaf' de Chamonix
mais y’a rien a faire faut
que tu me rattrapes ça avec du makeup
parce que moi je sors pas à la Folie Douce
avec cette espèce de visage de vieux cul de babouin.
Je vais voir ce que je peux faire.
Merci chérie.
Voilà je suis fière de moi.
Déjà ?
C’est vite réglé avec moi.
Qu’est-ce que t’as fait Alice ?
J’ai unifié le teint
- C’est bien comme ça ?
- Tu te fous de ma gueule ou quoi ?
Il fallait cacher le rouge.
Là on dirait un steak tartare.
Bon bah ça va je vais pas flinguer tout mon fond de teint
qui m’a coûté une blinde juste parce que
Madame sait pas protéger capital solei.
Tu le payes pas ton fond de teint.
Oui bah ça tu le dis à personne.
Il est bon ce vin chaud.
Ouais mais tu crois pas qu’on a un peu abusé là ?
Parce que moi j’ai pas du tout envie
de mourir étouffée sous la neige.
Ah non merci.
Mais chérie cet aprem, on fait pas du ski.
J’ai prévu l’hélicoptère.
Mais je te crois pas.
Oh mon dieu, mais on va faire des photos sublimes.
Garçon ? 2 autres vins chauds
3 vins chauds.
Mais attends moi.
Attends tu veux qu’on fasse cette photo ?
Bah oui, regarde comme c’est beau.
Être en maillot de bain devant la montagne
c’est prendre à contre-pied l’hiver.
Là on a juste a se mettre sur le balcon
On pose devant le Mont Blanc et hop, c’est dans la boite.
Zoé c’est mort, moi je fais pas ça.
Tu plaisantes ou quoi ? Ça va faire des milliers de likes.
Écoute, je sais pas pour toi,
mais moi ça fait des semaines que j’enchaîne
Croziflette, tartiflette, raclette, tout ce qui se termine en ette
Donc si tu veux, sous mon pull, au niveau du legging
regarde pas les jonctions.
donc si tu fais la photo, tu la fais toute seule, tu te débrouilles.
Ouais, c’est ce que je vais faire.
Pardon.
Alice, la porte elle est fermée.
Alice, tu peux m’ouvrir la porte s’il te plaît ?
Alice, je suis bloquée, dehors.
Alice, tu m’entends ou quoi ?
Je sais que tu m’entends Alice.
Zoé, le spa à Chamonix, c’est trop une bonne idée.
Bah ouais.
Puis là on fait le bain chaud mais après on va aller à la cascade.
À 15 degrés elle est
ça permet d’alterner le chaud-froid, chaud-froid
faut faire ça plusieurs fois pour bien rafermir ta peau.
mais on y va pas longtemps, on y va juste 20 secondes.
OK on y va à 3.
1, 2, 3.
Mais Alice, qu’est-ce que tu fais ?
Mais t’étais où ?
Non mais là j’alterne le chaud-chaud-chaud.
et l’année prochaine je ferai le froid-froid-froid.
Vas-y ma chérie, regarde-moi.
Relaxe-toi, un moment relaxant.
Une autre position des jambes peut-être ?
Regarde au loin.
- Mais je lis.
- Montre-moi le livre en même temps.
Alice je suis désolée,
tu peux te dépécher s’il te plaît ?
C’est bon là c’est terminé, on peut y aller ?
Mais non je fais une photo, merci.
Non mais ça 45 minutes qu’on attend là,
les enfants sont dans le froid, on est fatigué.
Mais qu’est-ce que ça peut me faire ?
Je m’en fous.
Je peux pas faire une photo paisible,
si y’a des pouilleux tout autour, merci.
Non mais il faut y aller là je crois.
Zoé, on va la faire cette photo, OK ?
Tranquille, seule au monde, regarde au loin.
Non, vous êtes pas seul au monde.
Toi ta gueule
Le regard.
J’ai vu cette photo sur Instagram, on fait la même ?
Ah ouais.
Ça va faire des likes.
Vas-y souffle !
Alors là, y’a aucun flocon, faut que tu souffles plus fort.
Bah oui mais c’est pas de ma faute,
la neige est toute dure aussi.
Non mais souffle plus fort on voit pas les flocons.
Mais je fais ce que je peux,
je peux pas souffler plus fort, après j’hyperventille
Je le fais une dernière fois,
après j’arrête, je m’en fous Alice.
Oui bah souffle plus fort et ça fera une belle photo.
Effectivement, elle est bien dure.
Elle est belle la photo ?
J’ai prévu pleins d’activités
pour les prochains jours, tu vas kiffer.
- Oh c’est trop bien.
- On va faire des photos.
Zoé, je veux pas te vexer
mais sur ta dernière photos Instagram
t’as zéro like.
Non, ça c’est pas possible.
Non, c’est plutôt toi qui a zéro like sur ta dernière photo.
Mais c’est pas possible.
Ah bah si en fait c’est écrit là.
Ah enfin, ils ont enlevé les likes sur Instagram.
bah oui, ça fait un moment qu’ils en parlaient.
Bonne journée Mesdemoiselles.
Viens on se barre, on rentre chez nous.
bah oui je regarde le premier train en fait.
Ça fait -des jours qu’on se pèle le cul , tout ça pour ça.
Ne t’enerve pas Alice.
- Pourquoi ils ont enlevé les likes ?
- Arrête, c’est pas de ma faute, OK ?